[Music]
blonde one yep Brian Scott was just
checking once you arrived in the morning
members thank you very much for
attending this morning would read out
the emergency procedures first of all
should we be required to evacuate the
building which you please leave the
building by the nearest available exit
there is one fire exit in this room you
need to evacuate the room do so by the
glass door the external fire xscape
staircase
please hold both handrails in case the
stairs are wet or slippery if anyone is
an ID use the stairs but they please
allow others to exit the room before
they go out to the fire escape door
where they can be given assistance our
assembly point will be in the public
carpark at the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect a belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note this meeting will be audio
recorded can i please remind members to
switch off your mobile phones or turn
them to silent moving on to the agenda I
have got some comments I would like to
make
before we get into the pot of the the
body of the agenda today but we'll do
items 1 to 4 before I can further
comment so we've got the apologies for
absence placing you know none
non-members attending
Minister I'm sorry yeah Board minutes
the meeting held on note some take the
November accept those is good yep thank
you very much and declarations of
interest
polyester is across right thank you very
much
I think officers have asked me to read a
statement in relation to joint strategic
plan across South Essex which I will and
we if members want copies of it we will
arrange for that to be distributed to
you no problem with that at all the
amount of paper that was forwarded to us
it was horrendous
it was totally if you tried to read
every page I think I'm going to be up to
New Year there's an apology's which was
you know not acceptable
hopefully that could ease subsequent
email clarifying some of the information
that is really supporting documentation
in relation to other councils policies
relieve some of the concerns but how I
intend to go through this if we can is
that as we're deaf see each item on I'm
sure we will read officers comments in
each agenda item Natalie will give a
pricey on each item you can then ask her
questions if there's anything that we
need to clarify subsequently then she
will forward answers to you if if
they're not very about your phone
right the offices of fast manases to
Madrid this out this may terrifying a
few issues as members will have noted
that have been documents published
without reference to to tea to strategic
planning and the delivery of a joint
strategic plan across South Essex the
council signed a Memorandum of
Understanding with five other South
Essex authorities being as erdan
brentwood castle point Southend and
thorough in January 2018 this being
followed by a joint statement of common
ground which is to be considered at the
meeting of the full count Rockford for
council on the 17th of July 2018 members
will also note the local development
scheme sets out a proposed timetable for
the preparation of a joint strategic
plan for south ethics
whilst this is not an agenda item for
this meeting as the statement of common
ground is to be taken to the full
council I thought it might be useful to
provide some brief context underpinning
this work when counts when the council
reviewed the statutory timetable for
preparing his new local plan it was
envisaged that policymaking would follow
the traditional three staged approach to
enable an aspirational a deliverable
plan to be formulated the review of the
CAO councils current planning policies
stated with an early engagement program
where the strategic planning team went
out into the local communities to
involve them in the consideration of the
issues that the district tastes and
potential future opportunities this
program was followed by the most recent
consultation of an initial issues and
options document earlier this year
however the client making climate has
changed considerably
over the last five to ten years with the
renew with the removal of regional
planning system publication of the
national planning policy framework and
the planning and practice guides those
two challenges case law are more
recently proposals to the amendment of
the national planning policy framework
and the planning practice guidance most
significantly for plan making the latter
relates to how they need how the need
for new homes is calculated and
ultimately met across the country
subsequently has been recognized that
there is a need to deal with a number of
key strategic issues in partnership with
our neighbors to ensure that they are
effectively addressed and planned for
such strategic issues for within the
remit the duty to cooperate which is the
legal requirement that the council would
need to demonstrate to an independent
planning inspector had been met joint
planning across South Essex however is
in its infancy and will involve as it
progresses should members have any
questions these will be noted today and
written responses will be provided in
due course
if you want a copy of this
I asked Natalie to produce something to
give you a bit of guidance we are quite
happy to get this forwarded to you if
anybody wants it I'll give that not so
would you even fold that tour members
posing that way right
I think briefly I've covered two points
that I wanted to in regards the quantity
of volume of paperwork that we received
having spoken to Natalie
I don't think there was much he could do
to to avoid it was what it was and we've
had to do it the main criteria as I
understand from Natalie is that the item
agenda 5 is the only one that we need to
make a recommendation to full council
for via gajeong
I shared your your concern I mean
thankfully my appeared Thank You Sonia
for that it was helpful to me to have
the favor of God because I couldn't have
possibly viewed them on screen waves and
it's disappeared nature
hi I wondered whether we could have had
other meetings of this policy committee
to receive these evidence documents
earlier maybe we had more meetings we
can have best documents but then in a
single meeting I can certainly see as
the JSP and our part in it our local
plan precedes that there will be far
more documentation there's going to be
critical I can think of issues like
highways I can think of other major
infrastructural considerations which you
know although they're evidence I think
there's a need for members to have
sufficient time to look at that evidence
determining whether the council
satisfied with the evidence-base I don't
think it's simply a case of saying
that's the evidence that's it it's on
the table
if we're not satisfied that the evidence
meets all the criteria that we would see
from that and certainly if there are
questions we may have to go back to
consultants or others I think we can
indeed have more time to do that if I
may John I think you've just said the
exactly 30 same conversation as I and
actually independently with June I don't
think I share your view entirely no
probably battle but I don't think the
information was available as far as I'm
aware this when this not claimed this
was the first time I knew about it and
as far as I'm aware it's aside for me
thankful for councillor Ward so so let
me just read you but I think we've
registered quite clearly that we have
concerns in line with what you've said I
know it will be very disappointed if we
have to go down this road again now my
my suggestion when do you thought these
turned up that's the veritable London
bus used to be sampling bustles for
privatizing
but if it does happen again I think
we're gonna have to have more than one
meeting fully according to these these
issues I don't mind spending the whole
day here if that's what everyone desires
but I don't think that's desirable
I think people's focus needs to be
dragged afraid already
yeah to a sharp point yep rather than
spread across you know five or six
important document for the agreement I
would say if they're not all in one then
we have a meeting a week that's probably
as it's evidence no huge time pressures
in actually having them put you know
into the into the library I would
suggest we need to do more on them and
just hope
looked at them insufficient data I'm
gonna say to him I haven't managed to
these I think insufficient detail
because they have turn that I've
endeavored to to you know read
conclusions introduction summaries but I
think I should have done more and I
didn't have the time to do more I think
that needs to be recorded John I
disagree with you I think I think it's a
common view and then hopefully offices
and the portfolio holder will take this
back and we hopefully we won't go down
this road again can I just come into
this I did register very very strongly
my feelings with Natalie with regard to
this some of these documents have come
through originally and I have seen them
so I can see as I've gone through but I
really do appreciate that to actually
read and digest and understand because
in fairness item five what is going
forward on that all the rest are the
basis of the assessments are deceptions
and everything that is drawn from what
is in those documents and I think it is
quite reasonable that members should
also have the opportunity to make and
draw their own conclusions from the
evidence so that they can make fair
debate in regards to that because that's
going to be very very important
we all have a different view on how
things should be done and I think we
will need to have you know come together
on a view so that we can all go forward
on a joint consents or way so I feel
that yes I think that you agree with me
as well because of leave and such like
she said we should all have gone out a
lot earlier whatever happened I don't
know he's good it's gonna be water under
the bridge now but I said this cannot
happen again this can not happen again
this is totally unfair on members of
this committee to be able to look and
understand and digest what is a vast
amount of information to be able to make
any conclusions with regard to what
we're trying to do because it all slots
in but you need time to digest and
understand the information and facts
that are presented to you know things in
your thinking I think going forward
and when we go through this with nothing
I think going forward we need to put a
time tome in place even if it's short
notice meeting you know we we will try
and do it but how the document comes you
know whatever we got to do it's not sit
on it for you know we have a quick phone
round or whatever we need to do but if
we have to pick them off as John said
one a week or wonderful night then
that's what we'll do and we'll go
through okay
right moving on then having registered
they are concerned about all this
have any problems at all I think we've
all shared this view over to you Natalie
for item number five to give you a
pricey and their members ask any
questions that they so desire
okay so item 5 is the revised life
development scheme to support local plan
making members will note that we've had
a number of iterations since we
commenced a review of the council's
adopted planning policies 2015 this
latest update
follows the most recent consultation on
the on the local plan and provides an
update to our expected timetable patient
it also includes a broad timetable for
the joint strategic plan which mentioned
is really thin joint there is some
information in both the covering the
pool and the appendix as well which is
that I would rather scheme itself or the
South Wessex joint strategic plan
provides a bit more context on that and
as I mentioned the time scales that
we're looking to work to or so and we're
looking for a recommendation from this
subcommittee to fall Council to adopt
that long time tone
to support unmaking because we are also
considering the joint plan as well as a
local plan the timetable that we've got
in this report and in the local Roman
scheme does follow that which have
already gone to committees other local
authorities in South Wessex so we are
one of many that is following that same
these purses
- can I just ask if it is basically what
we are proposing here in line with what
is being proposed to all the other
councils and so and there's been no
feedback to many of those yet that there
is any accuser
no no nothing that's been reported to us
I see from the plan for app that they'll
be talking about
after third options consultation summer
water
be concerned about that because summers
not a great time to have a consultation
without Peter
if autumn means just over the running to
the September and then think that's a
great time either
we probably know that's when the schools
go back
families are readjusting so some
families are just taking their holidays
because they choose not to take it at
that time I think it would be a very
poor thing this council it's another
consultation that's a traditional
holiday time I think I don't and I don't
think making it longer by experience
helps I don't think starting in the
middle of December and finishing in the
middle of March actually helped anything
at all I think it was about the timing
of the launch I think it's about making
sure that we choose a time which is
going to be appropriate for our
residents to be able to respond to a
preferred options which in the direction
of travel in the seller is towards
garden villages or towns actually given
the responses from the inspector on
North Essex
consultation it seems that is going to
be a lot longer than was originally
thought
I'm not sure that the JSP will deliver
in the spring as it as it suggests I
think it would be much later you might
say in that face that's not a problem
because our plan will be five off but on
the other hand we should be planning for
our residents and not just simply you
know something for something else to
happen a bit brexit style really
directing style is hoping something will
happen and we would be doing the same I
think we need to knock this out until
October or every third options
consultation and that might in fact
actually help them cater for a fallback
position if the spring is not delivered
I said are anyway so I won't be
supporting the recommendation and that's
a decision of a crew okay
mmm have you any comments on that last
it was October seems a reasonable time
to me or have you got any other dating
no I mean we've tried to work out our
revised timetable to fit in with the
strategic plan we don't want there to be
any real overlap with in terms of
consultation we don't want people to get
confused with if there are two
consultations happen at the same time at
different scales so I'm happy to to
maybe push you back to autumn winter if
that's helpful
just to give us that rather than
committing us to a specific month we
have that flexibility still there are
there are other issues to consider with
in terms of evidence being available
time
publish a plan as well as taking into
consideration the capacity team to
deliver within a certain time scale so I
would prefer if it was still a bit broad
we can revise the main component that's
going near at the time if it's helpful
to pinpoint the consultation periods and
we have the flexibility to to do that we
are required to keep it up to date so if
there are any delays for example in the
joint strategic plan coming forward next
spring we do have the option of updating
the local variants going to reflect
revised timetable all for that plan as
well as our local plan if we feel there
is not going to be kissing the targets
that we we're currently aiming for
responsibly I mean that's a helpful
response I'm grateful to hear that
I think there's a problem with hauling
things I'd be a bit concerned that you
know it will be my hands of his December
ignite I agree I think we've got to be
rather more specific and ensure that you
know we do complete this consultation if
that fits with what's happened before
and makes it do I think we've got a
completed by the end of November in
which case that goes back the other way
and says you need to start by a certain
date I think John I think we've
highlight or you've highlighted an issue
I think the best thing we can do is
we've highlighted two officers to come
back with a proposal to us if we're
going to have it and I think we need to
put this in in plan anyway more regular
meetings of this committee even if we
have one next month or whatever come
back to us then with your reviewed
revised whatever phrase you want to use
of what the plan is and we'll consider
it then I mean we're not going to be
negative but we want and we appreciate
the the timetable that you have to work
to know so think that we need to make
sure that we're on board and we know
what's going on because we don't want to
find ourselves a bit light or this not
being puts you into a corner where we've
got no time to say well actually no we
don't them to do this or we don't think
this right
and if if you're quite happy to go with
that we'll have a regular meeting even
if it's just to say right this is the
unnoticed update we have one in you know
later this month or the latest beginning
of all this this is where we've moved on
to even if it's a 10-minute meeting and
then if I come in on this having
attended all the asylum meetings there
I've got a very good feeling in regards
to representatives from other districts
and boroughs and although they're very
very keen everybody wants to work
together towards an end and of course
the end has always been the concept that
we cannot get infrastructure on our own
then the only way we're going to get
infrastructure is with this joy
strategic plan that's the only way that
we're going to be big enough to be able
to make a representation to come to get
there but I I kind of do understand what
you're coming in as far as this is John
they're in as much as that you know we
need a wee bit more flexibility in being
able to understand we want to get a
definitive end
what about consultation that we've got
but we also need to work back to when
that should start and I can probably
understand as well maybe October
November if we're looking at 19 and 24
both of those times especially where I
do recognize that a lot of consultative
documents are coming to us extremely the
last minute which is very very annoying
believe you me it really is annoying and
we need time to be able to filter those
in so that we're taking everybody
together on this so you know everybody
is content and happy
and that to me as important as it is to
every other district imperative that you
know that we've been talking with that
they have no sign concerns with members
making sure that they fully understand
all the evidence that is coming forward
everything that's going in there so I
have no problem with making something a
wee bit more positive about this rather
than being airy-fairy
into a time so we've actually got hang
on
we need to have this definitively let's
say for November that gives us breathing
space in there we can actually start to
have the evidence the documents we can
start to have a proper consultation
where people filled I had a lot of
involvement in this and we get the
feedback now of course a lot of maybe
there are going to be people who are not
going to be happy with what goes on but
ultimately we have to come to a decision
which is going to be for the benefit of
everything and I can't do concur with
your feelings on them
so I just was come on
it's eerie
that's a starting point
it's possible and the basicity
maintains that
like since
and if there's suddenly something happen
I was nearly 60-percent sir I think this
is what we were highlighted very high
diving this is something I don't think
some of these new police could be within
our scope to resolve them I think it's
going to be outside factors that may
about the shooting bring this into play
with regard to the recommendation I've
just been speaking to Natalie and I it
takes exceptions Cummings
this is jus to go to full council next
week week after with the recommendation
promise now what we've just been trying
to knock together here is that it is
proposed subcommittee recommends to
counsel and excit be adopted and we've
just put in on quite happy to talk about
this subject to october november twenty
nineteen being the target date but this
will be kept under constant review and
may need to be attended that meant may
need to be amended as time proceeds
which i think would give a
recommendation to full council
potentially we agree with it but it may
need to be adopted a halters if we if we
feel that's the case and then we will go
back to forecast of June
to a daily record good day
okay we are in the process of hopefully
increasing the capacity of the tank so
Dunn has recently been made up to senior
planner and we're hoping that
we have got advert for a planet to
support us three by the Local Plan
process and the joint planning work as
well and so we are looking to increase
the capacity of the
team overall with regard to the resource
issue for us on the joint plan making
side that is still in its infancy that
work the government's arrangements are
still being formulated and there will be
it's likely there will be an element of
resource required from authority but
this stage we're not quite sure how
that's going to be
we can take any concerns you have got
resourcing back to shore Matthew 11 to
to consider
we are I think we're quite confident
that we can deliver something
next year by October November time but
the important thing is that we do keep
our local diamond scheme under review as
you may make noted and we have three
authorities in South Wessex who have
been identified by the government and
they have received intervention that is
brentwood ambassador and who are being
closely monitored by the government at
the moment because they'd have had a
local in space for quite a number of
years now they are being held to their
timetable and the government is closely
monitoring that and requires adequate
justification for any changes to that
timetable as to why they're not going to
meet their previous target and cost
points
is in a slightly different situation in
that the government has also highlighted
them that they are considering whether
what the Secretary of State will
of the County Council for example to
intervene in that process so there is a
lot of pressure on local authorities to
deliver our plan we do have obviously
have an adopted plan but that the longer
it takes for us to produce a plan more
out of date that gets and the the
government is quite clear that to have
an out of date plan is not acceptable
you need to be proactive in the planning
and although we do have recurrence where
your policies and we have been
progressing on reviewing the government
is taking a keen interest in everybody
and they are looking at timetables on a
regular basis to check how we are
progressing there and whether
beep right to deliver a new
is new
in relation to
when this process was initiated
the original
there has been some seepage we have had
Changez entertained with us remember
style last year and it has been
difficult to recruit there are
challenges within the planning
okay
being able to attract permanent members
of staff so there has been some some
slippage there's also been issues with
with evidence and some cases and being
able to get back turned around in a
timely manner
so there are a number of different
factors that that can lead to slippage
in the timetable and that's
unfortunately has been the case for us
at watch of it for example we haven't
been able to finalize our follow into
the most recent consultation we have to
prioritize our resources where we can
for example the run-up to this committee
we obviously have to do a lot of prep
work in the background it's deliver the
reports to yourselves in a timely manner
as possible
but we are hoping to have another 20
very shortly which Hall were members to
look in detail at some of the and the
issues that have been raised in tourists
on cell phones but the thing we pretty
much the joint planning aspect
in addition we'll have come
thank you
benefits to
as far as you
right it's not a cool it's a it's an
issue that's going to be dealt with we
don't have a choice of whether we
cooperate with other councils that's a
fact of life now we are obliged to do it
if we don't then we'll end up my castle
pointed in in trouble with the inspector
e in December 2016 when when they didn't
cooperate with their fellow councils so
this connects with what you said in
relation yeah I know it's I mean I think
we've we've highlighted our concerns
that we need to have more meetings I
think we've highlighted concerns for the
resources I think we've highlighted
jazzhub mentioned a more specific date
for the preferred options decoration
October November but somewhere along the
line we've got to keep this under review
it may be even if we have a more regular
meeting we cannot change the situation
because of outside factors but we will
do what we can to make sure that we are
as as on the ball as we can and we're a
supportive of officers as we can be but
we can't predict the future we will do
we're all here to do the best we can for
our residents and that we have certain
let's do requirements that were obliged
to meet and we will do it now if we the
committee of highlighted issues and we
can't there's only so much we can do as
a subcommittee for Council hopefully
we'll take notice and hopefully
make necessary remedial actions to
address our concerns but that will be
for another 30 odd counselors to them to
make that view if I could just sort of
add to this I mean one of the things
that has been discussed this is
generally over with the sale is that
every council must proceed with their
own local plans that was very very
important the whole concept was
eventually we will be working in sync
with the joint strategic plans but at
this moment
everybody has to proceed with their
local plan and the strategic plan is
also carrying on above it where we're
going to try and harmonize together but
a very important point that weapon I was
speaking to Natalie some time back with
the reports that were coming through as
you said well in the main that the
reports that we've got are pretty well
complete the problem is we are still
waiting for evidential documents to come
in to them so you know a lot of the
problems has been receiving evidence to
actually complete reports that go
forward so you know it's not as if you
know they hadn't been working really
really hard to complete the
documentation it's a simple fact and
there are a lot of evidence is coming
through and quite light on so you know
but I see the documents incomplete with
just X's which have got to be filled in
and this just haven't got the actual
facts to put in them yet so the only
they're working very hard to get the
stuff out but we are we are subject to
other authorities and another consult
EES who are sending stuff to us not just
I mean we I think we are actually spun
around quite long enough to be honest
this setting this anybody's got anything
else but I mean we have a recommendation
I think we can adapt that to try and
meet trap your concerns John
I think we've highlighted a number of
issues that are causing us concerns as a
subcommittee and I I would suggest that
subject to your views that we will go
along with the recommendation but we
will draft some amendments to the
recommendation which will highlight our
concerns and we will work on that now to
come up with some some wording that is
all of us can sign up to or agree to if
there is such a it's not too
okay morning
situation
where are we we definitely
oh it's probably about 70% completely
but it got to about 77 completely and
then other things have taken over so
it's really it's as of when I can so
when when when he's a realistic I think
we were aiming for a September okay
yeah yeah well let's try and work out
what we're gonna say I mean we have a
recommendation the draft attached to a
page lightly adopted subject to October
November 2019 in the preferred options
regulation 16 but we will keep this
under constant review
and may need to amend as the time for
press a probe progresses I mean I'm open
I share your concerns on all this but we
need to say something some
recommendation to Council though
yeah we don't support that we can all
support but it is reflecting our
concerns I think we need to make sure in
the report of the minutes of this
meeting are available I know that it's
going to be difficult but it's important
because if we're making a recommendation
which basically takes out the bad system
actually we're not it's a subject to
hear there's got to be reasons yeah if
we don't then there'll be autumn of
members standing up in full council
saying that you've still got the plan
say summer
you've got the subject to but have you
recognized the issues of a consultation
around holidays you see I know that
sounds obvious but the most obvious is
the things that men were so concerned
about by clever word the reason for this
this recommendation which is an adjunct
or subject to is because we recognize
these concerns so what do we say well
I'm sorry I'm just asking will the
minutes of this committee be available
for full counsel essentially chairman
and asking Sonya from the subcommittee
then we'll cancel on Tuesday thank you
okay kill me stupid sometimes in another
way September we know well what we gonna
do George we're gonna have another
meeting in August and downs gonna tell
us in August if he's been like he's up
to 85 percent by which time we will be
talking to accounts the Wold Matthew and
everybody else saying where are we going
because we can't keep putting all this
stuff back
you know yes because I mean with the
prioritization dan we're not we're not
criticizing we're trying to work out in
support yeah we because if this
committee keeps expressing concern of
and we've been on other committees where
counsel Mason myself express concern
many years ago and results came out of
it but somebody's got a highlight so
here's a resource issue okay
that's what - Jen and so are we
how we how are we going to do with this
recommendation we can only say and then
say subject - I don't know something -
because that isn't our jump in other
words you're keeping the planner cities
and you're saying well it may say that
but
you mean this I suppose will you what
you're saying is that it's going to be
made the words have got to indicate that
the plan has been changed to to that
effect that we have the - what I'm
trying to do is give a recommendation to
Council expressing appreciating what
we've got to do what we've got to
recommend about how the notion could be
the four council changes that from what
it says at the moment just to what we
are recommending
that has changed to take attention
yeah okay that's positive
yeah okay clear juvenile Mike another is
Sonia counsel long they will give forth
yeah
yeah yes
and that incorporates the recommendation
that we are expecting to see the
feedback from the issues and options in
September
hopefully hopefully maybe one saying I'm
sorry but the plan is to chamber I need
to know yeah the intention is September
but we will have a meeting we but we
will be careful Bayes provides before
that if that isn't going to happen it's
just basically means that it's work yeah
it doesn't step in to have you away but
then no can i I'm not entirely clear you
wanting to recommend that the plan is
amended and specifically what do you
want amended in the planner because I
think we need to put that consultation
takes place 20 1994 stop and that regard
see me feedback on the issues and
options consultation
that this is plan of for September
September but we'll keep it under 20
hours in view and we also yeah no she's
not she's document is September 2018
my chairman if I just come in if we go
to three point seven which then will it
will help us to understand what is being
said for regulation 18 yes okay yeah so
so in regard to that for regulation 18
we are recommending that it be put back
to October November as a definitive yes
and then we're looking at regulation 19
for the same because it would have to
follow that same framework I don't I
don't we will be completely out sick if
we left it right in that way so we need
to put that in I believe we can safely
leave regulation 22 as it is for winter
2020 because again we're coming into
that later period there won't be any
consultation in that period it'll just
it'll just be for us to okay a little
prepare yeah and then it's up to the
playing inspector
that director yeah but our members happy
did that be that the item that goes
through and do members feel that they
can support that going to council we
can't no okay
okay this report will be appended to the
subcommittee yeah so you've got that
yeah yeah okay we're all happy well I
think that will be highlighted do we
need to for that new member I think that
will be in the affairs of the
subcommittee's in the report
okay it's nothing to do with the
amendment though the resource issue is a
separate issue that needs addressing yes
because that would resource issue
yeah the resource issue is affecting or
is separate from the amendments we're
talking about it it's a contributory
factor to why we're having to do this
yeah to whatever meeting of this may
take you so in other words this is an
issue
saying yeah we'd like a report back fine
can we leave that the head off yeah like
that
can you say that louder oh oh what what
I think we need to have a meeting in
August and hopefully as portfolio I'll
go in you will come back with it's
looking like resources and results we
want an update in August where we've
moved on to how we think we're going to
address these issues to ensure that we
can get our regulation 18:09 changed in
time and also the options that should be
on in September 2018 are on time all
right five onto that item number six
nationally which is the growth economic
growth strategy
so the economic growth strategy was
presented to a meeting of the executive
in December last year that focus is
primarily on the economic development
element of my team which is under
Chancellor Keon it finally that document
sets out all key priorities over the
next few years in industry at that
meeting of the executive offices
so that they would also delivering clear
implementation plan which would set out
the key actions that look to undertake
over the next financial year to deliver
against those those four priorities this
is also supported by ten people with
indicators so that we can more closely
monitor the economic development
function now we've got a new
regeneration suppose the implementation
planner is quite it's quite detailed and
quite specific and doesn't specifically
but the implementation plan itself is
actually going to the executive now on
the 12th of July I believe to be
considered for approval this question
and the very first page of Appendix
table every single one one attempt says
the number of and yet there's a little
time I just wonder why there aren't any
numbers and all cycles is this otherwise
it's points
in some it's very it's quite challenging
sometimes to put a target against it
because it's very dependent on other
factors for example the number of
planned applications that come in it
depends on the number that are relevant
to the function itself the same with
same with them things like development
briefs funding brands it depends on what
funding marks are available and what
businesses actually want to take up
those opportunities we've been out to
lots of different businesses in the past
about various drugs but just some
businesses just don't have the time or
optically interested in actually
pursuing specific German this doesn't do
it for me
it's a kpo and he's a number it's going
to have to be redraft into makes you
know to effectively stay though it's
going to be whatever the number is
pointless having a KPI
is that possible from what you've just
said that isn't an option you you can't
get it's just going to be a guesstimate
you put any number in your life yeah you
can we can put targets in and but what
what do you do if you can't meet them
but there's other up this gentle simply
explain why which you don't take the
eyes ruled out yeah yeah calm down you
you put in another but it's pointless
isn't it I mean I've been asked to read
this huge water stuff and the first
thing I came to was a bunch of kpi's
with no numbers now I lost the question
I think you use lightly save excuse me
but we should put a set of nerve disease
and it's a guesstimate it's an estimate
they always are and then the question
then we know well what do you do if you
don't meet them and I just said explain
which is what it's all about but if I'm
playing devil's advocate here if there
is no evidence to support the number
that you put any movie as a guesstimate
what is your achieving I mean Natalie
can put in all sorts of numbers here
they delete them because they're a waste
of time
I don't is that that's not an option at
the moment we don't have any numbers to
to monitor against so this will be our
first year that we'll be monitoring
these KPIs if you like in the next
iteration next year we can use this year
and that way the moment we don't have
anything Jean was terminated my
experience tells me this in commerce if
it's a KPI and the number is booked to
it even though it may be difficult and
if that number is not met or wildly
exceeding X for their explanations on
providing to have none is pointless but
if the explanation is well we have no
evidence and it was just a guesstimate
in the first place and what we actually
achieving we chose Jenna I'd say to me
there is no point in calling something
they came behind if you're thankful to
get a key performance indicator there is
no point in having
if there's no target for it do you want
to come in George because it's your area
you know I do work with cake girls
myself and start you from a blank [ __ ]
you have to have some type of feedback
from your stats and yeah tomorrow we
have another stats available but through
our own personal experience we could to
John's point have a guesstimate but
uneducated gifts or what think API that
you could be with with a possible -
return on the KPI value which allows the
officers to actually comment on whether
they are KPI was met or not at the
moment that's the approach all who take
and leave the 10 based off the educated
guess with a plus/minus value and then
use that as a base income in the
forthcoming future - OGS assess where we
stand
from the previous year now I think we
are tensed up exactly after this and we
can go through the temples of God
present to say a executive executive but
in my view that's what I was gonna say
an executive that I thought you would I
see yeah yeah okay I can I can see where
the issue is if we're starting from
scratch on something it has to have a
basis of what the scratches and if we're
going to a point I score and number then
okay it may be wrong it doesn't matter I
think you've got to have an assumption
of what a number should be an ideal
assumption and I can I can actually
understand what jerk where John's coming
from because you've got to have
something to start with you might be
wrong doesn't matter the simple fact is
that you're not at fault if you're wrong
oh you're now looking at is okay you
made assumptions now you can actually
work on facts as you progress through
the year and you're gonna have a proper
figure so you'll actually know where
you're going to come to so I think that
okay if that to me makes perfect sense
if we're going to put it out as a KPI
then we start off with our assumptions
it doesn't matter if they're right wrong
it you know I'm going to get shown on
this one the simple fact is if we've got
a basis of we're an educated guess is
going to going to be right or wrong it
doesn't matter because at the end of the
year of the period that we're measuring
it we'll be able to understand more more
power in our assumptions are working and
are we meeting them exceed exceeding
them or whatever
but we just need to mend this in I
thought you said you'll take to the
executive yes
there aren't any penalties but we have a
temporary regeneration of the place in
our team and we would be looking at the
KPIs and work that part of the team's
undertaking to try and justify business
case for making that a permanent post
you can have time if they're educated
assumptions and you keep less your
assumption against actually protect
yours it means that as advice for your
first year
[Music]
Oh
my dear
can we can we just say we're trying to
work out was being recommended to the
executive here and that we we say here
that subject to the comments by the
executive the implementation of plan of
economic growth and we would have to put
an amendment in there saying that it we
believe that there should be a marathon
targets indicating the key performance
indicators numerical targets but also
assumptions relating to the engineering
target was like with without the targets
without the assumptions how can you
actually get your your your you'll be
taking this to the executive your yes I
am okay but I'll speak to Natalie
afterwards okay
we have great bday happy with that how
do you have a good venture yeah pleased
to hear that subcommittee is going to be
recommending
and seeing that target Supreme place yep
with all the caveats of course it will
be able to it's called becoming growth
so growth implies improvement if we see
against the particular parameter that
it's not being achieved or it's been
achieved at a level we don't think
satisfactory than we up there Larry
that's the way we that's the way we're
going to assess the term growth which is
what started me off you know we we we've
done we put in I think what you've asked
for John yeah George you've heard the
concerns you're the portfolio you'll be
presenting it to exactly legitimate and
asking for an amendment to be okay
can we then agree with the
recommendation the southeast economic
development needs assessment attached to
the appendix a be notice as evidence and
publish to the council's website and the
issues regarding to the executive be
amended as you pointed out Sonia okay
fine moving on next item number right
here we go seven story
[Applause]
[Music]
as members will note we prepared a
separate paper specifically on the
ruptured elements that were coming out
the emergency athletic study which was
presented in November last year this was
because as we've as counsel was already
alluded to certain elements of the
studies were completed ahead of others
but we were able to pick up Rochon
elements to support the publication
about issues and options document the
report in front of the a is that
complete study and so it's the ruptured
element within the wider context of
staff actually I should point out that
this South basic study was commissioned
for Brentwood's became part of the
ethnicity area in terms of doing plan
Baker so it doesn't include
anything to do with Brentwood's that
just focuses on the
Suffolk authorities of dazzling castle
point works with zapping and therapy
the hopefully does that main sub Essex
finding
there are issues for the sub-region
please take account the effects of
London where businesses are being
squeezed out from do two things only for
wisdom we've got the wide range of
commercial transport films instruction
business activity across the submarine
sub region including than the gate a
degree in thorak and also an errand
the economic climate for supper success
is expected to change over the next 50
to 20 years and there are various
economic challenges which will impact
the forests of South Wessex the report
provides a brief outline of what those
likely challenges are going to be and it
broadly sets out using a full possible
model-based approach of how each local
authority would likely to form over the
next 15 to 20 years
in terms of different types of
businesses and industries that are
actually located within each area it
does this merrily through a combined
scenario approach licking these specific
challenges and opportunities for each
local authority area and the table on
page
7.4 is a broad outline of the supply
demand for each local authority in South
Bay States and for South Wessex as a
whole for watchword this hasn't changed
it's still a lot of demand for between 7
and 16
just come in what I'm going to be making
an assumption that Brentwood will have
to be included in this at some time so
will be that we have what we have in
front of us again we have a situation
with with Brentwood having been part of
a sailor we're going to have to take
what evidence we've got from them and
that's going to be incorporated so again
you know we've got a situation that
we're taking into consideration document
here which will be subject to change any
questions on what's been presented so
far Georgia no this is obvious obvious
changes to being whatever is agree
they're practicing because we're talking
about economic together and you know you
I have no doubt but whatever agreement
is night this will need to be looked at
again
it main beneficial impacts
neutral implants or it may have
extremely mini-game incision and I
suppose one would like to know that with
the South Essex consortium is gonna
consider that I think I think all we can
do at the moment is to to endorse the
recommendation but if we're gonna have
more regular meetings this can just be a
straight from the agenda item every time
and even if it's there's nothing more
there is something to it was a question
I think I think I think I'm afraid I
mean we've got evidence which is
actually evidence which would be
probably the end of last year in
fairness and last year so evidence you
know he's not particularly up-to-date he
never can be because by the time to
research the it's out day anyway you've
only got a snapshot of what it was at a
certain time and that's and that's what
happens and that's all we can work on
realistically but I think obviously it's
going to make changes
I'm more than optimistic disposition
with regard to things by having heard
from the various boroughs and districts
on what they are thinking
with regard to their own areas there
there is quite substantial optimism
actually coming through from those
members I've spoken with so I feel very
positive about about things I must admit
but again it is a moving face because
continually and we're going to keep it
under review I think you like the point
I think we all recognize this throw out
that group right away through South
Essex so you know we're going to
observation all the time so can we agree
to the recommendation for the game
Thanks we need well I think this is
another area we accept the
recommendation yes but if we this can
just be a routine agenda item along with
all the other stuff and if you just say
there is nothing further to report yes
month so be it
yeah yeah and you update us as we go
along here moving on then to local plan
evidence base our basic retail study
item number types
previous study we've just discussed this
is again a joint study process I said it
doesn't include brentwood due to the
timing and it specifically focus focus
on retail and leisure so members would
have received a topic paper in November
last year prior to the issues and
options consultation setting out the
multidistrict element of that study as
it was emerging just to enable us to
progress in a timely manner without plan
monkey retail study looks across South
ethics and identified the main hierarchy
of different centers and how they
function in relation to each other where
were the drools are over
we have lakeside Basildon and South Bend
which are they
key shopping
Rita general retail rules for consumers
across South ethics rules I have to
remind all of centers outside the area
including champ stood which whether it's
a significant amount of leakage so you
watch furred as a district sits within
this this wider context again it's
taking a forecasting model approach the
approach has been preferred its housing
led one Soviet ties in quite nicely with
the findings of the 27 inch mark which
were emerging around about the same time
that this was being these piece of work
that was being worked on so it six to a
nine similarly with the feedback because
where the need to stick to a line and
population projections we
economic in the previous study and we've
retail shopping patents in this study
you look at these main findings for sale
physics as I mentioned it looks at the
composition of centers for across South
Wessex
the three largest settlements in lots of
districts so radium Rochford are
identified as town sentence due to their
the way that they they function serve
the local communities it doesn't really
touch on anything smaller than those
areas noting that they're the villages
much smaller catchment from the large
towns in the district goes through
various now into quite a lot of detail
about expenditure and leakage within out
of different areas Watchers has its own
niche of the district in
and there are various recommendations
within that study as well as to how you
as to how he choked authorities extra
time and increase its market share
thank you I think I mean this is a
highly contagious this one I think is
changing by the week for example you
know Railly is benefitting now because
there's no banks in rockford or poplar
so if you want to talk to anybody about
building societies banks or whatever you
come to write it you know I mean online
the whole shooting match over the
predictive 20,000 job losses in retail
this year this to my mind is is the
report and by the time we have another
update the latest report will coming out
nationally and I think we're even or
depressing to be honest new person John
here
Oh
this assessment is probably one of the
hardest assessments to
juice
into the future
I'm gonna
basis
their plans
floorspace going to have a big impact
Changez and
some really going to have to specialize
or they many wells
he's happening that another town senses
around country
these importance have
in the Lucid out quite substantially
and that affects how we look how the
plan we've got to listen the evidence
base for that plan as well
think about a growth and develop housing
etc yeah Chuck just just one comment
about up to page five which wasn't as
far as I've got
to 17 beautiful an assessment of the
retail meets needs a 231 considering a
plan to 237 and I'll call it the
consortium if it's I just like the term
its considering to 20 2015 so you know
this is just a snapshot and for our
presentation to the inspectors we're
gonna have to go further the 231
otherwise okay remember absolutely and I
would agree with that and has been
discussed recently things are changing
so quickly and that sector at the moment
that we would need to do a an up-to-date
study at the right point in time for us
to make sure what we're planning for is
correct
the face of high streets is is certainly
changing they still have a role to play
but it's what that role is in each area
that we need to be just big collection
points for a life size I think your hope
is not like I mean I've got Michael
Tighe square right up my street there's
no point in having anything fast and I
blame them
Castle Road they've been restaurants
there is no requirement and so I think
we have to note this again peepers
posted on the update are things they say
when you when you see these big stores
just making corporate decisions we're
gonna close funky about 50 stores what
chances we increase our population yeah
and we do it by housing then you know
they've got to have a sustained they've
got to be sustainable and if the retail
isn't sustainable for the numbers that
we're talking about then that's you know
a major it's kind of a catch-22 is new
you know some of you know I think but
that's why it's so pretty
yeah if I'm just coming with regard to
discussions that we've had and this is
at that same high level is it really is
fundamentally understanding that we want
to be future-proofed where we can
yeah so we're going to have a little bit
crystal ball viewing we can see how
things are moving where it's so
important to be you know have really
good quality broadband I think that's
one of the last things that we looked at
with regard to infrastructure the great
changes that are occurring and they are
happening at a pice and it's very
difficult to keep up with that pace
because there are so many things that
are being invented created as we go
along we just got to be so open-minded
and flexible to challenge and I think
that's going to be one of the important
key key things with regard to this
[Music]
something which is obviously close to my
heart because I mean broadband is you
know at the end States absolutely
essential both for personal business
living type and there's no question
about that
except to say that I can honestly tell
you that the new infrastructure hope
them escape hasn't never probably didn't
notwithstanding the fact that it was a
requirement it hasn't you probably guess
I've had quite a few conversations open
range
marita quite clear that there are large
areas in our district that are working
off the infrastructure there's 30 or 40
years old and they're patching every day
to be honest they are if you look at I
think what's going to be important for
us is to do some sort of study with this
because there is the superfast project
which is sponsored through its the
County Council it shows you where the
super past project is going to deliver
and I've discovered at least in all that
is going to be delivered through over
the land from poles there's going to be
delivered from polymers the fiber is
actually other poles already it is a bet
and is able to be distributed and of
course those people who receive their
telephony by pops if you like during
terms are going to get fiber to the home
those that are not
that has to be have it underground if
it's not duct if it can't be done so
they're going to be pockets all over our
district where we may well consider
development but won't be able to support
and even for personal or business I
think that as far as this committee
gutters and this panelists we need to do
the proper study on the current position
on broadband availability and the
performance that is promised by who can
reach and that for the future and more
particularly for those areas that we
made in our one way or another the
further develop the retail manufacturing
we're taking that I think joke this is
enterprise yeah love you okay
can you just take it on board I'll take
it on board and report back by Natalie
Natalie and and give some comment okay
yeah right
let's keep moving on sorry yeah no it
was on my mind yeah that's fine job of
it but it's Enterprise isn't this this
crack on with it right moving on that's
a now we're on to flooding I think
hungry $13.99 item 9
and so in 2011 we'll publish a strategic
flood risk assessment services dates to
the American agencies modeling since
then the most recent ones to its climate
change predictions so Rochford has again
worked with its neighbors downstream
cost point and suffered with the support
of Essex County Council to deliver an
update to that study it's a level 1
assessment which means it's fairly high
level it looks a potential
for each locations and how how far and
have deep any flood leader is likely
likely to be should one of those
breaches the report sets out the main
aims and methodology for undertaking the
sfra
sort of data etc that have been used and
it sets about the main findings all for
watching district
No
through them comparison
at South Americans to their shoreline
well she was highlighting how to
we had with them with
the involvement
have this
you know very modest be part of
she's hairy which she's
racist [ __ ] man they were concerned
about
our engagement of
that they contracted emotions
the assessments something we're doing
so in relation to this much broader
scale he's still and they became
important area
how much
so it was the shoreline management plan
the
and that's something slightly different
to this plants we do have a shoreline
management plan which covers watch a
district I can't remember still my head
what date that is but that's led by the
Environment Agency Joe
probably would have been a scam to count
got something slightly different that
looks at the only the condition of the
flood defenses in the area and walk the
wrong agencies
approach should be to maintaining or not
those flood defenses so it's something
slightly different to plan that width of
the for you which is more of an
evidence-based document which looks at
well I mean what if this happens
where would you've got a raft that the
environment agencies found what they're
actually doing in terms of maintenance
for the the faculty
just just to know that that one is the
Biosciences I was involved right but we
regard fairness the city fancies
there yeah she's not necessarily come
from
the responsibility for
yeah
that's I am about if I imagine that's
the agreement that they have to be from
an agency and Belarus they would
maintain
30 days for maintenance
or scale very much kept them safe yeah I
voted no yeah he's with the American
agency repeatedly
body that's responsible for that those
type of works about
to my knowledge I have engaged with us
in relation to
things might be happening
necessary
for fairly obvious reasons anything else
on on this document
I said his statism you know what again
I've been endorsed the recommendation of
going me and just keep that date going
update and on the whole issue as with no
clue there's nothing to report you say
there's nothing to report
okay moving on to item number taming you
know plan evidence base I'm - okay CCC
15 purpose chips in traveler
accommodation assessment similar to the
retail and the economic development
needs assessment studies members would
have received a topic paper back in
November highlighting the watch district
elements of the emerging Essex wide
study
[ __ ] Java community
again the full report wasn't available
at the time so we reuse the the elements
of the stage that had already emerged
for Roger district so this report looks
at and brings together all of the - all
of the as its authorities involved in
that study and it puts what - district
within that wider wider context then
members may note that the update for
Jets and travelers came about as a
result of changes to the national policy
statement traveler sites and the change
in the definition of what can be
finished from the traveler and the
planning policy purposes so someone who
in ethnic tips in Charlotte but no
longer
traveling's work for example is not
considered in traveler or planning
purposes
and as as we prepare our individual
funds we need to consider how we meet
the needs of all of the traveling
community in the district whether they
do or don't meet the national definition
it's in the plan could save a full
travel size so report before you three
sets out the the wider context
for the ethics assessment and what main
findings are
and it sets out there a total of 82
households that meet the definition 416
are unknown and 298 that definitely
don't meet the definitions is real
mixture across the county within the
wider context of the National Planning
statement and by going to all the
details involved in there but we did ask
for an update to the watch district
element in January 18 Wilson stated
following
more recent appeals and decisions that
had been made so that was upstate as of
January 2018 and where that time has
moved on since then we are looking to
you to keep that updated particular to
all the joint planning work
yeah this is something that
bring up
kuqali on here
you
it was suggested
of the recent plane
in relation to planning application
especially Darnell so careful
have
part of that process clapping policy
in relation to
pansy
same teacher
the basis for those application
in relation to how
councillor company's current client
relations
the side
the applications that come through our
gypsy sites and it was suggestive
between commercials
as to whether and it might be possible
Oh
allocation of summits for travelers
on many features of
and
to capture light for closer relations
I said I'm pretty cool so I can see what
sort of
you would be in relation to that rather
than having their specific
that basis you could have a developer
develop the pitches
inclusive scatter bird the machine
that's why it's how can I put it that
there are lots of things that we've
actually looked at in ideas with regard
to that I I think one of the things that
that we felt initially was when we went
up to the one that is maintained in
Braintree I think it is called Chester
sorry in Colchester which was the way
that that was managed we saw that as an
ideal solution bearing in mind that the
White was run it seemed as if it was an
ideal solution bearing in mind that they
are travelers that they need easy access
to to motorway routes and various things
like that but obviously they do need to
have provision you know educational
provision of medical provisions those
type of things that you know would be
expected so I I think initially where I
think you're referred to mission is farm
which has been extremely difficult to
bring forward and has been a problem for
us especially bearing in mind the last
time an inspector looked at it on an
appeal and and came down on decision in
making a site permanent which went to
appeal it presents us with a difficulty
which the council as a whole is going to
have to recognize though we're going to
have to do something to be able to
accommodate and I think we're all going
to have to recognise that we're going to
have to come up with solutions albeit is
there a way in which we can bring
Mitchell ins farm forward if not what do
we do as an alternative
maintain film courses to several aspects
for this review of evidence there's the
main or arguably 15 pitches which are
provided by to make basis of local
authorities for justice I certainly
don't think that developers are likely
to agree to an allocation of edges to
individual sites that they're seeking
commercial advantage then I put that as
carefully as the thing that bothers me
is we're talking about now talking about
transitional provisions and that kind of
bothers me I suppose on one slide my
head says but they're doing it anyway
and they're simply bowling up to Hall
Cherry Orchard Park the place and rady
which is just obviously you don't
feature job fish you think bowling up
and all these places and just taking
transitional provisions
and I know he taught this report talks
about the counts of engaging with others
as to how this issue is dealt but I'm
not sure I'm not sure at all we should
be marking transition transition
provisions for travelers that are
currently moving through our districts
commercial basis the other issue of
course is the the situation in
Parliament where there is lengthy debate
about how the traveling fraternity is
perceived and I'm trying to be tactful
they're traveling for commercial reasons
in other words they're working through
an area doing the things I think I guess
my response from this is to say I think
we need to do something about the
pitches for permanency and do something
about the temporary permission that
we've granted and ensure that we are
able to to deal with the transition of
those
but in terms of translating I'm not keen
to provide in our plan for transition
sites because I kind of feel that they
won't be transition sites there will be
in one way or another
permanently utilized and they could be
considerably larger in our experience
that they're being pitches so I would
say in if you if you're representing us
these consortium meetings don't get
these too excited or interested in
providing transition sites I would say
I'd be more interested in seeing an
appropriate law that prevents it from
being necessary
[Laughter]
we're noting the time noting the report
have concerns about both aspects in
particular transition the transition for
the transient provision quick and point
of clarification on the report so the
report does their part and providing
permanent sites and access
what we'd need to fry them permanently
it doesn't go so far as to address the
transit issue that's something that
we're going to it's going to be
considered separately across Essex how
that's dealt with is yet to be
determined
but there's a lot more work that needs
to go into working out what our baseline
evidence is all that the Essex County
our travelers unit for our district does
deal with any or assistance in dealing
with any unauthorized encumbrance that
may take place and they have quite
learnt of data from across the county so
as a group of authorities we need to
look at this in a bit more detail work
out what our actual baseline is where
those incumbents mainly taking place and
then once we've got that evidence live
category and what we actually do with it
I guess I'm encouraging you to do very
little
you know let's just go you know it's
maybe one else please with as well
because I really do fear these these
transit divisions it's not necessarily
the case that it would be one transit
site possibly across
planetary period
individual fan the question more with
that actually being possible over
Bing
expanding become bigger and the issue is
is how to take
period we could end up having Connor on
I love this needle again it's it's
crystal balling because we know that
there is MPs who are very active in
trying to bring some legislation into
force that may influence some of these
issues that that we are expressing here
I think all we can do at the moment is
accept the the recommendation I think
planning and all these other issues
provision express it Jonah me I'm very
willing to but I think that in the day
we accept the recommendation I think
we're all pretty much it will be an
issue for the local for each individual
planning application through development
committee to decide what they feel but
at the time and I think I think is is a
very difficult subject to discuss
22
I'm not sure whether they have been
defined but that was an option that's an
option that
possibly going to be incidental no it
shouldn't the transit issue we're
considering as a district no the transit
issue is mentioned in both the ethics
report and the individual local thirteen
course as well but the it doesn't go
into any detail it says we know what the
situation is both please we need to do
more work on this means that there will
be a separate piece of work that looks
specifically at that because we we need
to do that from a planning perspective
and but the the report that's in front
of you at the moment doesn't actually
make any firm recommendation
not much later eventually doesn't match
emergency stop
yep
[Music]
okay okay movement aside was emergency
to stop
I doubt that that's been specifically
defined it probably would be included in
a report on on transit pollution we
don't even should we don't even just say
as we mentioned specific sites and
transit permission
oh okay yep yeah I have other teachers
to know if the police decided this is an
emergency scenario we want them put in
here they would have the package Aisha
driving and that's what they've done in
other places well I've been in portfolio
that they deliberately put them in one
area because I know where they are and
and and and they can control the
situation and Joan John Fisher it was
about five or six turned up and then as
more turned up they were all acted into
the same area because then they know but
I think we're moving on to another area
[Music]
coming to 92 thank you we will close the
meeting at eleven twelve
thank you very much we will make a Sonya
try and organize some meetings regular
meetings on a monthly basis even if
there's nothing if there's nothing to
report then we sent a me out to Memphis
to say you know it's media termina
meeting where there's nothing or
whatever but I think we need to allocate
or monthly basis I'm meeting
thank you
don't take your apologies off the ends
what do you want though is it
[Music]
[Music]
you said before the meeting